all right guys so you've probably seen a
few battles already online the s23 ultra
versus the all-new iPhone 15 Pro Max but
have you seen it at night time video
photos Battle Royale let's get down to
it
so here's the deal we're not going to be
doing talking about specs on these
phones we're going to show you how they
perform there's been plenty of videos
talking about the specs on both of these
devices let's get down to talking about
the front-facing camera both the 12
megapixel we're going to start with the
iPhone 15 Pro Max first with video 4K 25
because Zach you're shooting 4K 25 right
yep yes indeed we're gonna do 4K 25 here
now I could shoot in log I could shoot
in prores and then maybe I'll do a
little bit of that as well so you can
see a little bit of grading that out as
Zachy does on this but uh always clean
the camera with your your shirt a little
tip trick there for you I'm recording
right now you're hearing the audio out
of the phone and the video quality
looking pretty good is it better than
the 14 pro Max I'm gonna say it's less
hdre I think they've been toned that
down a little bit looks a bit more
natural and I might I'm actually
enjoying this exactly let's walk around
so we get some lights we get some glares
coming into Play Because here's the
thing with the iPhones right look at
that right there the flares on the rear
cameras they're a little bit more severe
than the front-facing camera but there's
a little bit of flare there called the
JJ Abrams effect but what do you guys
think let me know in the comment section
below now we're here now we're going to
test out this in the log the Samsung
can't do log this can so let's see how
that looks right now now we're shooting
in prores log 4K 25p this is a massive
file Zach is going to hate me for
editing this because he doesn't use a
Mac right now he's currently using a PC
to edit this I'm sorry Jackie but prores
is going to text your Premiere but it's
okay you can grade it you can show the
audience how good it looks created a
little bit better dynamic range we're
going to see how Luke's is not so over
sharpened as it is straight out of
camera but let us know in the comment
section below what you guys think it is
front-facing camera prores log
4K 25. I'm not finding 4K 25p here but
I'm finding 4K 30 I'm using the pro
video mode that should be equivalent to
what Apple's producing on the iPhone 15
Pro Max looking at the image on the
display right now it's a little bit more
contrasty a little bit more Punchy uh
the skin Tone's a bit more muted on this
it could be the promotivist who knows
but anyway you're getting a sense of
what it looks like and how the mics pick
up as well I'm liking the fact that
Samsung actually has audio levels here
on the print facing in the Pro mode I
like that I appreciate that Apple
doesn't give us that you can get that in
a third-party Apple course but you're
not getting it out of the iPhone let's
talk about flaring real quick there's
some flaring happening right there a
little bit more Super than the iPhone
based on what I'm seeing on the display
but let me know what you guys think in
the comments section below by the way
there's no log out of the Native app on
the Samsung so we're not going to shoot
a log but you're getting what 4k30 looks
like right now so next we're going to
test the front-facing camera for selfies
for photos now Apple's touting I think
24 megapixels as the default versus 12.
not too sure if that's with the
front-facing camera or not I know it's
for the rear but nonetheless you guys
you guys let us know in the comments
which one you prefer we're going for the
Samsung right now got a little bit of
light coming from this uh food stall
right here
see I raised my hand it snaps that's the
only thing I like about Samsung the hand
thing
awesome Apple doesn't have that Samsung
does but if you're Italian like me and
you wipe your hands a lot it's going to
just start taking photos and all of a
sudden there's a lot of photos being
taken but nonetheless let me know what
you guys think based on what I'm seeing
on the display right now a little bit
more contrasty a little bit more uh Less
in the shadows but this thing keeps
taking photos I really got to chop this
hand gesture or I gotta stop talking
with my hand because now I can talk and
I'm not going to get photos taken anyway
let's try the iPhone right now so now
we've got this raw 12 mode and but you
don't get raw Max mode on this Apple's
settings on this are a little bit
different you're gonna there's a
different language you're gonna have to
learn with the iPhone 15 Pro Max in
terms of its hot photography but looking
at the display and the colors I'm
preferring the iPhone hands down
and I can talk with my hands and it's
not activating that's a good thing it's
meant for Italians like me hey I want to
talk like this doesn't activate it
all right guys let me know what you guys
think in the comment section Below
Samsung versus iPhone based on what I'm
seeing on the displays I'm gonna go for
iPhone on this for both video and for
photos with the front-facing camera plus
you have a few more options in terms of
frame rates on this as well for videos
so I think iPhone is going to take the
win anyway Let's test the rear cameras
right now so this is using the main
camera out of the iPhone 15 Pro Max
we're doing it a 4K 25p and uh This is
Gonna match what Zach is shooting on
right now currently with the video so
you're guys going to see what it looks
like now we're going to walk into lights
like this there's some proof cells
behind me walk around see what the
flares are like are you going to see
flares is it distracting I can't tell
because the camera's flipped over but
I'm guessing based on my testing of the
phone thus far this video looks
absolutely phenomenal Apple has
definitely upgraded these cameras is it
better than the 14 pro Max slightly
better but there's always going to be an
evolutionary upgrade not a revolutionary
upgrade the phones are already so good
as it is right now but this is
absolutely fantastic so just to flex
some phone muscles on this one we're in
action mode 2.8k
prores lock that's right better
stabilization as I'm walking and talking
in prores log in action mode
tell me another phone that has this
native out of it I'm waiting and I'm
listening for you guys to respond in the
comments
there isn't any because Apple's
dominating in the space anyway let's see
what it looks like as I'm walking and
I'm talking here the stabilization
should be on point it's always going to
say it needs more light required needs
more light required but there's plenty
of light here let me know what you guys
think how is this action mode in prores
log
damn that's good that's a big jump up
from last year
I'm actually liking the log to be honest
with you and by the way if you're using
Final Cut you update if you updated
Final Cut already you're going to see
that there is an apple Lut already built
in when you go into the uh the log
profile of it so you can already just
grade it as it is but a little bit of a
temperature for you guys but that's what
we have here
with
action mode
dude looks so good it really looks good
you know one thing I like about the log
it doesn't have that over sharpening
it's more natural and it's designed
based on the color profile to match if
you're going to be using this as a
secondary camera to your Cinema cameras
or any let's say Sony Nikon Canon you're
going to be shooting in log you can
color grade and match pretty much
awesome on this it looks good now
looking at this it is lower light
there's some noise creeping in there's
definitely some Grain on this I may need
to get out of action mode to show you
what it looks like without that
we'll do that right now okay now we're
doing 4K 25p in log on the rear cameras
because we can't oh I've got that flight
flashing in look at that light hitting
my face you see that Jackie you see that
okay just finding the light finding the
light finding the light find the light
oh snap now if I go behind me do we snap
flare do you guys see that flare right
there or you want to know why there's a
light there it's actually projecting
Manchurian lamb hot pot
I'm now on my training lamp Hot Pot how
about that anyway guys that's what it
looks like in prores in the back of it
all right now we're testing the ultra
wide
camera 4k 25p on the iPhone 15 Pro Max
now obviously the stabilization may not
be as good as the main camera but it
still stabilized it's still pretty good
maybe a little bit of warping because
we're super ultra wide as I'm walking
around here and I'm doing this but yeah
not too bad at all you want to go Ultra
wide for your videos to get that you
know that that effect you've got it
right here because we don't have 25p on
this camera seems for whatever reason we
have 24 and 30. I'm going to shoot in 30
here we're using the main camera for
video in pro video mode because I
figured that is the most equivalent to
what Apple's offering in the 15 Pro Max
let me know what you guys think exactly
let's back up a little bit the beat just
more of a fair you know comparison I'm
going to get more to the light so people
can actually see what I look like in the
light versus going into a darker area
and say hey you guys didn't test that
correctly you're not being honest with
it because I hear you I know there's
some die-hard Samsung fans out there I
get you I hear you I understand you I'm
trying to make this as Fair as possible
I have no skin in the game on this
whoever's the winners ever is the winner
because when we tested the s23 ultra
earlier this year against the 14 pro Max
the s23 ultra came out ahead when it
came to video
over the 14 pro Max will that be the
case with the 15 Pro Max we're gonna
find out very very soon anyway this is
what it looks like I've been talking to
you I've been chatting with you let me
know what you guys think in the comment
section below so now we're going to take
a picture of this sort of iconic wall
that's in Chinatown here like an old
Singapore bit of a kampung vibe to it
and we're going to test the iPhone
15 Pro Max first raw Max mode I have to
say I prefer the colors out of the 15
Pro Max this year versus the 14 pro Max
the 14 pro Max had it was much more
warmer and uh a little bit as I
mentioned to HDR but
also good you know
this is tough looking at both of these
here it's really I would say that you're
seeing the HDR kick in on the Samsung a
bit more and as a result
it it exposes correctly but it's missing
that character and what I mean by
characters sometimes when you're taking
a photo it doesn't have to be perfectly
exposed not all the Shadows have to be
exposed perfectly all the highlights
that have to be exposed perfectly
sometimes a little under exposure
sometimes a little bit more contrast
sometimes
these these inaccuracies make an image
look more interesting and special than
everything's being exposed correctly the
iPhone is handling this scenery better
in my personal opinion than the Samsung
now you may disagree with me when you
see the images on the display some I
prefer how Samsung renders it but in my
personal taste I prefer how Apple's
doing it this time now last time with
the 4T Pro Max I prefer the Samsung so
again
it all varies on which phone you're
using but Apple hasn't proved this and
it shows in this scenario as well so now
we're going to test some low light in a
dark alley now the reason we have a
light on me now is because Zach is using
the June crane 4 which has a light built
in on it so but when we're doing the
test the light will be off right Jackie
yes all right before we do our test
though here's a quick message from our
sponsor this video is brought to you by
MSI meet the summit E6 then flip
featuring the latest 12th gen Intel Core
i7 processor RTX 30 series graphics and
a 16 inch Quad HD Plus touchscreen panel
with a 360 degree hinge it lets you
unleash maximum productivity with up to
11 hours of battery life at just 2
kilograms the summit e16 flip offers
unprecedented performance and
functionality allowing you to work and
play anywhere anytime Hi how are you
can I get your silhouette shot so
looking at both of these images I wanted
to test something very interesting here
a backlight against the subject and the
gentleman is very kind enough to sit
there for me to see the flaring from the
iPhone
because obviously they said there's a
new coating on the lenses because the
previous iPhones just flared it's like
they hire JJ Abrams to just add Flair in
every photo and see how it compared
against the Samsung
looking at these images here now the
Samsung does a very good job in terms of
bringing up the Shadows a bit more to
see more detail in the gentleman's shirt
he's got a plaid shirt the iPhone not so
much but what the iPhone does on this it
exposes correctly and the flare isn't as
severe as what I would previously see on
the 14 pro Max and the 13 Etc et cetera
Etc it's more well controlled so much so
it's even more well controlled than the
Samsung s23 Ultra so I got to give Apple
some credit there they've improved the
flaring now we haven't tested all of it
yet but so far JJ Abrams isn't or at
least hasn't been hired to you know do
flaring on the 15 Pro Max as of my test
thus far is it the stupidest test of all
time
oh okay
now this is the most mundane shot I
think out of the entire video but go
with me on this I want to see what it'd
be like in low light in terms of how
each phone handles exposing for these
dark subjects fold the table red chairs
guys like I said it ain't hard
looking at both of these the Samsung
really exposes a lot
however it's not natural
the iPhone
does a tremendous job of exposing not
too much but realistic but the detail
especially in the wretch in the red
chairs and the can
is evident
very impressive Apple
some steps up in the 15 Pro Max honestly
I wasn't expecting this I thought the
Samsung would walk away with this one
five times over because it does very
well in the light but it does a very
good job anyway now it's my duty to take
a nighttime shot of Zaki as we normally
do here because Zachy needs a lot of
shots for Tinder he's recently single
helping him out oh wow look at that chin
down a little bit bringing out the 15
Pro Max now oh
oh hello oh man
when you guys see these two images of
Zaki he's looking very handsome but the
detail on the 15 Pro Max trumps the
Samsung
very much so there's a lot of noise
reduction happening in the Samsung
apples not doing it as much and the
color correction the exposure for low
light is really really impressive okay
let's move on Jackie more tests to do
fantastic
thank you sir thank you so much now one
of the features on that portrait of Tony
who is very kind enough to allow us to
take his photo is with the iPhone you no
longer have to go into portrait mode you
can just go into photo mode once it
detects a face human face or an animal
it will actually give you the option in
the edit to go back into portrait mode
and looking at this real quick here I
got to say captures the hair on this
beard very well nice fall off good
definition on his face the color of her
shirt's accurate the Hat's accurate the
white balance is accurate
I'm very very happy on that now looking
at the Samsung it's washed out portrait
mode is not bad to be honest with you
the portrait mode on the Samsung is
pretty good we've talked about this
sometimes it's warmer and sometimes it's
cooler in this case the skin tones are
much more accurate out of the 15 Pro Max
and the color of her shirt versus the
Samsung s23 Ultra and the winner this is
the Apple 15 Pro Max now talking about
telephoto for a second I know apple has
a new system inside their iPhone 15 Pro
Max for telephoto and comparing against
the Samsung
Samsung has a really good telephoto lens
and just shooting this bird real quick
here
I think you can see the images
Samsung still takes it when it comes to
the telephoto Apple's improved
definitely
um and it goes with the five times
optically applicable what it is and you
go 10 times plus digitally but Samsung
has that 10 times I believe it's
optically inside of this and it just
looks so much better so yeah
Gotta Give it to Samsung on that I do
want to preface this video by saying
this is that look the s23 ultra has been
out for almost
eight months now nine months so we're
looking at older technology versus the
iPhone 15 Pro Max and like we had with
the battle with the s23 ultra versus the
14 pro Max
you know what I mean there is going to
be a difference in terms of the
technology so this is not to say the s23
ultra is a bad phone it's not it's been
one of the best phones in terms of
content creation video and photography
for the entire year it's just that the
iPhone 15 Pro Max with the newer
technology the newer algorithms what
they're doing it's just best in the s23
ultra in many ways right now so for your
Samsung fans out there don't get upset
you got an s24 coming very very soon in
a few months and it'll probably be
better than the 15 Pro Max in many ways
it's and ever never ending cycle but
that's just the beauty of these tests
and that's what we have fun with it but
with that guys
Me and Jackie want to tell you one thing
is that this is both of our last videos
for Geek culture
um it's been a pleasure to be part of
the team for the past year and a half
you've been with them for what almost
gonna be five years five years I'll say
four and a half for now five years about
a year and a half for me and uh I'm
still continuing on my own channel you
can check me out there at Bobby tinelli
and you might see Zacky once in a while
there as well coming up on board never
know yeah never know never know and uh
but you know what we want you guys to do
is also subscribe to geek culture follow
them there's a great team of people
there they're really putting out a lot
of great content as of late and just
give them support we will be supporting
as well and you never never know you may
see us pop on a video here too but uh
with that this will be our last video as
more consistent creators here on the
channel we want to thank you guys for
the support thank you for the love we
greatly appreciate it any final Awards
Zacky yeah just like the thing the rest
of the crew man we've worked hard and we
keep on working hard yeah all the best
to you guys and uh definitely more
content coming your way guys that's
right definitely for sure take care guys
be safe bye adios
thank you